Here's the whole meaning for the dot product. For any two arbitrary coordinates.
We'll go through a piece at a time. This first part we're used to. If you have a
normalized a and b vector, then the cosine of the angle between the two is the
dot product. However, when a or b are not normalized, in other words the length
is not equal to one, the dot product also consists of these two factors. The
length of a times the length of b times the cosine of the angle between the 2.
To sum up, you can think of a coordinate as moving due to a rotation or staying
still, and just being recategorized by a new set of axes. To throw 1 more term
at you, these 3 axes are called a basis, and this is a term you'll see as soon
as you get into vector math at all.